لقد بدأت للتو التجارب البشرية بالأمس ،
كيف ستعرف قريبًا بالنظر إلى ذلك ، هل تعتقد
أنك ستعرف ما إذا كان لقاحك يعمل
الآن بعد أن كان في التجارب البشرية ، نعم لقد
بدأنا هذا الأسبوع وعادة ما يستغرق الأمر
ثلاثة أو أربعة أشهر لإثبات
أن اللقاح آمن وهذا في الواقع
السؤال الأول الأكثر أهمية ثم
نريد معرفة ما إذا كان يتم تحمله جيدًا
وما إذا كان ينتج استجابة من الجسم المضاد
قد تكون وقائية بعد تلك
الأشهر الثلاثة أو الأربعة الأولى ، فانتقل
إلى السؤال هل يحمي
وسيستغرق ذلك عدة أشهر أيضًا  لذلك
أعتقد حقًا أننا نتحدث عن الوصول
إلى نهاية العام
وأوائل العام المقبل قبل أن نحصل على
إجابة نهائية ،
حسنًا ، إذا كنت تفعل ثلاثة أو
أربعة أشهر في مايو يونيو يوليو
/ أغسطس و  فأنت تقول إن
عليك القيام بجزء الفعالية من التجربة
الذي سيصل بك إلى نهاية العام ، لذا
فهذا أوائل العام المقبل ، لذلك عندما
تراجع الرئيس عن
توقعه بشأن هافين  لقاح ga
بنهاية العام الذي يتوافق مع ما
تقوله ولكنك تقول الآن أن
هذا لا يزال في عام 2021 قبل أن
تعرف تمامًا ما إذا كان يعمل أم لا ، فلا داعي حقًا
لحقن الأشخاص العاديين به
تعرف جزءًا منه مثل ذلك  الكثير مع
هذا الوباء يعتمد آرون على ما
يحدث ، إنه وضع مرن للغاية إذا كان
لا يزال لدينا الكثير من انتقال العدوى
في الخريف عندما تنتقل هذه التجارب إلى
مرحلة اختبار فعاليتها ، فسنحصل على
إجابة أسرع ولكن إذا كانت
الحالات تتدهور  يستغرق وقتًا أطول لأنك
يجب أن تتراكم عدوى كافية في
ذراع التحكم لمعرفة ما إذا كان ذراع اللقاح
في الدراسة يحدث فرقًا ،
نعم أعتقد أننا نتحدث عن
شيئين مختلفين أحدهما هو مدى
السرعة التي سيوفرها لنا العلم  مع
إجابة وأنت تعلم أن الأمر
سيستغرق بعض الوقت ثم
السؤال الآخر هو كيف يمكننا التحرك بشكل سريع
بالتوازي لزيادة الإنتاج
حتى نحصل على الإجابة بأن هذا
اللقاح أو أي لقاح قيد التشغيل
سيكون من المفيد أن يتم نشر ذلك
في المجموعات السكانية التي لدينا القدرة
على تكثيف الجهود بسرعة ، لذلك تحدث الكثير من الأشياء
بالتوازي والتي
تحدث عادةً في سلسلة نقوم بها
في شهور والتي عادة ما يتم
القيام بها في سنوات
ولذا أعتقد أن هذا ما نتحدث
عنه في القيام بالأشياء نوعًا ما في نفس
الوقت ولكننا ما زلنا نعلم
أنك قلت إنني متفائل جيدًا أنه
لا يهم حقًا أن العلم سيعطينا
الإجابة هنا.
التجربة السريرية التي يتم التحكم فيها جيدًا ،
سنكتشف وسنعرف دون أدنى شك ما إذا كان
اللقاح يعمل أم لا ،
وسيخبرنا ذلك ما إذا كنا نمضي قدمًا في
نشر ملايين الجرعات أم لا